downtown minneapolis has the flare of a
ghost town these days
city hall and other municipal county and
state government buildings have been
fortified
the city spent several months planning
and preparing for what is likely to be
the highest profile trial in the history
of minnesota
razor wire brand new fencing and
concrete barriers
this is how minneapolis tried to secure
the hennepin county government center
this is where the derek chauvin tri
will start in just a few hours there
will be national guard troops here
police will be out in force here
to secure the proceedings inside all
around town
there's a noticeable strain in the air
because of the trial
there's a lot of tension especially this
all the defenses going up it just seems
like
escalation almost like they're already
prepping for the worst if it doesn't
stay peaceful it doesn't
but if justice is not served i don't
think it will
and it shouldn't no they may change uh
police policies but ain't nothing gonna
change out here though
the trial will begin with the
potentially lengthy process of jury
selection
the court has allocated up to three
weeks for that
ex-minneapolis police officer derek
chavin faces charges of second-degree
murder and second degree manslaughter
for the death of george floyd the 46
year old black man had been detained by
chauvin at this street corner 10 months
ago
on may 25th last year many say what has
since become george floyd square is
foremost
a symbol for the pain and grief this
community is still experiencing
emotions are running high firmly rooted
in deep mistrust for the police and the
u.s justice system
steve floyd leads a local neighborhood
organization called the agape movement
it aims at improving relations between
the community and law enforcement
he is concerned the trial will reopen
wounds oh it's not business as usual the
more
closer we get to the trial the more
intense and more emotional it gets
the more triggers reappear you know it
becomes more
brought from your consciousness of what
happened what we went through the last
10 months
minneapolis still shows plenty of scars
from the angry protests
the rioting and the violence that
followed the death of george floyd
burned out and completely destroyed
buildings piles of rubble serve as a
reminder of what potentially
can flare up and happen again here the
worst scenarios they
did protests get aggressive from the
beginning
that's the worst in anticipation of
reigniting social unrest during the
trial
which is expected to go on for months
minneapolis has spent millions on
beefing up security
half a million dollars alone on
barricading the city's police precinct
buildings
however as the world is watching what
happens next many here say
that there will be a much higher price
to pay if justice is not served for the
killing
of george floyd
well that report from dw correspondent
stephen simons
who joins us now from outside the court
welcome stefan so how are people
reacting to news of this delay
well actually they don't even know about
it yet i think
because the protesters which you saw in
the background here
an hour ago are all gone they are
marching
through the city what's left is the
national guard some national guard
soldiers
right in front of the hennepin county
government center where this trial was
starting this morning about an hour and
a half ago with
a little surprise jury selection is
delayed for one day so this will start
tomorrow not today why is that
because the prosecution um uh motioned
that as long as the defense as they had
planned and said
is going to the supreme court and trying
to get
clearance on a appeals court on an
appeals court decision that a
third murder charge is being back
allowed into the court as long as this
is happening they want to delay the
jury selection so all the jurors the
potential jurors and these are
dozens of people who were waiting to be
selected or dismissed
they are going home and come back
tomorrow and uh
for today court proceedings are halted
right so three weeks set aside for jury
selections that sounds like a long
time uh to pick one jury um
why is it likely to be so contentious
it is because of course this is a
landmark trial here for the state for
the city for the
united states of america i think and
maybe even for the world because
um you know it's all about fairness
impartiality of those jurors there is no
way that
anybody here in this community in
african-american community in the
community
where george floyd was actually killed
is that will accept anything but
a really impartial and fair
jury selection what does that mean you
cannot end up with
10 white people on the jury seats and
two black people for example
there needs to be par part impartiality
this is what protesters say this is what
community leaders of course want
and uh ask the court to deliver now this
is complicated because there is a
process
called voidia and that means that the
judge
the prosecution as well as the defense
can ask the potential jurors questions
and if they do not in the mind of a
prosecutor or
defense team lawyer qualify for the job
that means if they're not impartial if
they have
some notion against police or against
black people
then they're not qualifying so this will
be tedious work and as you said up to
three weeks for this
well it's needed they should take their
time for this otherwise this
trial is tainted off the bat all right
uh we'll leave it there good talking to
you uh stefan simons
in minneapolis thank you so much
you